I have to give you information. I will do it for you.
Okay.
I can do it. I just haven't done it because it takes more than like three hours.
I will do it. I have so many things to do, but Ricky...
I said I would do it.
But do it.
Okay.
It's just one week and we were supposed to do that.
Right?
You are going to do it.
You already said, no, I don't want to do it.
I want to pay a new ticket.
Okay.
If you have money, do it.
Because you...
Okay. I'll send you the information.
Yeah. You think that money...
How much do you have from your money?
By this time, I think that it's all and so on.
Yeah.
Right?
Well, look. I wanted to set up a high-saving EELs account.
We tried and then it fell through.
Just things kept happening and then it was all gone before I even knew it.
It's fine.
It's whatever.
The most important message that I just want to know what happened after we came from,
and then I'll be back in the morning. This was Friday night. I don't remember. You were tired, right? And we came here, I also was very tired. I had a conversation by phone. You were waiting here for probably 10 minutes until I arrived. Oh yeah.
I guess I went to bed. You were supposed to explain it because you were very tired. I don't know what happened that night.
I couldn't tell you. I remember. I was like, I can't remember.
You were all night after because next morning, there were happy. You can see. You can see me.
Thank you.